Speaker 1: Let's go to the discord phone lines
and hear from some of the folks in our audience.
We do this on the Friday show. You can find our
discord at David Pacman dot com slash discord.
That is the place for it. Let's start
today with Bert from New Jersey. Bert,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David, Hear me okay? Yes,
I can. Okay. Two questions comes from the
Trump Town hall. Couple of weeks ago. Senor,
Curious about your opinion? My opinion is there
has been a lot of pushback from the CNN people.
You know, how dare you give this guy a platform?
You know, basically empowering him. You know,
most of the time we hear Trump air you. He's
talking to Sean HANNITY. He's talking to Tucker
Carlson. It's like a, you know, Kim Jong un
being interviewed by North Korean state media.
You're not getting any real substance. We have
look at it. We're able to see him actually push
for what's right. And he actually like respond
to saying election was stolen and, you know,
saying he can leave his hand and, uh, declassified
documents. Right. So, like, for me, there
was value in seeing him having to actually be
confronted with this stuff in like talk about it
and left me feeling like, like to see it again.
You know, like, here's if you thought the same
or if you got the same reaction out of that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, here's the thing. In
principle, I agree with you. And there was some
pushback. The problem is and you know, Kaitlan
Collins, who hosted it, has gotten a lot of the
criticism. I don't know that any single person
Trump lies so much that it's a bigger task
than any one person can handle to actually
do justice to what should be the amount of
pushback that he should be getting. It's it's
an impossible position to be in. And so while
on the one hand, you're right, he was, quote,
confronted with the reality that nobody, nobody
in any kind of position of authority has found any
wrongdoing with 2020 or whatever the case may be,
it really wasn't enough. And his supporters saw it
and they were emboldened by how he wasn't going
to submit to CNN and whatever. So I don't know
if it really did any more good than it did harm.
That being said, CNN has every right to do town
halls with you know, they're doing one with Nikki
Haley. They're doing one with Pence, even though
Pence hasn't announced it. It's not that CNN
shouldn't be doing these events. It's just really
hard to do it justice and do it responsibly.
Speaker 3: Right. Yeah. No, it's totally fair.
Totally fair. And the other thing I think I
was going to ask you, too, is for yourself,
as you're sitting there watching this, Right.
Do you ever feel iconic, conflicted? Because
on one side, you know, the man's policies are
repulsive. Everything about him is terrible.
At the same time, he gives you material. Right.
And it's like it's exciting to talk about and
it's gives you so much spark. Right. So you're a
fierce of, like I say, rooting for him. But like,
as much as I hate him, part of me is like, well,
you know, this is great. He's back. We can talk
about all these things and ever get that feeling.
Speaker 1: I don't get the great he's back thing.
I mean, here's the thing. I have no control
or say over whether Trump's a candidate. I
don't and I have no control or say whether
corporate media gives the guy attention. I
do a show. There are always things happening
in this country. There will always be things
to talk about. And so is Trump entertaining
in a very kind of disturbing way where you
laugh to avoid crying? Absolutely. Do I?
I don't feel conflicted because I have
absolutely no involvement in the fact that
this guy is running again and he has tens
of millions of supporters. So I 100% agree
with what you're saying, but I don't I don't
have any kind of internal conflict. No.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Awesome. All right.
Speaker 1: Bert from Jersey, thank
you very much. Great to hear from you.